if you think Jimmy was exaggerating
about how much of a fan he is on Star
Wars here's a picture and this is you
this is Jamie taking a couple of his
kids to school yes that's not just look
how proud puppy and Daisy are really
being a teenage dad I'm trying to get
better at it and and I went to parents
evening and and stop being embarrassing
and I'm I hadn't owned only breathing
I'm trying to calibrate my embarrassing
nurse and that I felt was appropriate
that that's not yeah that's from
Pinewood Studios legit mold massive
chuffing around the growl of a misstep I
mean honestly credit to the real
stormtroopers because when you run with
that there's chafing strafing yeah yeah
and in America you'd have been shunned
but you think when you wear that you do
feel powerful
really yeah literally like a minute
after that I just walked out into the
street and just stopped her but a bus
the hilarious thing is the bus job as a
similar agencies that's I'm stopping
have you had any problems with the
rebellion he went